you're a subscriber to movie pass and
slightly you did not see Tom Cruise jump
out of a plane last weekend
[Music]
movie paths locked out subscribers from
seeing many blockbuster films like
Mission Impossible followed because of
its financial problems that's even
though users are paying a monthly fee to
see a movie a day the company also
announced it's raising that rate from
nine ninety-five a month to fourteen
ninety five within the next month the
stock of movie passed parent company
closed down 38 percent yesterday at just
fifty cents in a statement movie path
said we've begun making the necessary
changes to our service that will help us
continue to offer our members a high
value low cost in theater movie
experience Derek Thompson is senior
editor at the Atlantic Derek good
morning good morning I'm looking at this
statement from Mitch Lee Lowe the CEO of
movie pass this is almost like I mean I
hate to say this is like a suicide note
he says there are inconsistencies and
unreliability of our service over the
past few days I regret our lack of
proactive communication I mean it's
basically saying we've done everything
wrong that's right and the Internet
today is strewn with a bunch of
pre-mortem for this company and it is
beloved you know this is like Robert
Frost nothing gold can stay people love
this service but it was too good to be
true so let's talk about what this
service exactly did the consumer pays
$10 a month they get a little card they
can use that card every single day to
buy movie tickets but movie paths still
has to pay full freight for each movie
ticket how much is a movie that's a bad
deal for movie pass it's a terrible deal
for movie pass right if I go right down
the street and I buy a movie ticket
that's $15 so if I buy one movie ticket
a month not a day a month movie pass is
losing money
how is everybody how is that a business
model how didn't they realize they would
be paying more out of pocket than the
subscribers were paying to them I think
there are two answers that question the
first very simple answer is that it's
not a business model it is a consumer
giveaway package essentially that said
there are a lot of successful companies
that have grown to scale by losing money
Mitch Lowe came from Netflix which is
going to lose billions of dollars this
year to do exactly that
amazon.com did exactly that for decades
losing money every single year and now
there may be the most powerful company
in the world you could say for example
that uber is doing the exact same thing
all over the world right exactly there's
losing
so what do you need what's the
difference between a movie pass and a
Netflix the difference is investors and
to get investors you need a story you
need a story that says this is what
we're going to do we're going to sell
the consumers at a loss to build a
bigger product to sell them at
restaurants to build our data into a
grand new service movie pass doesn't
have that story there's clearly
something to the subscription model
though as you point out because now we
see AMC Theaters trying to do their own
version of it right exactly AMC Theaters
now has their own version of movie pass
it's called a list they charge $20 a
month for max 13 movies a month again
may be a great deal for consumers but
it's not like they're setting money on
fire well if you offer 30% off the
popcorn and a drink though you could
boost your sales inside and there you go
and see makes money on its popcorn on
its coca-cola on its MMS that are like
17 dollars a pop raise that's how great
movie theaters may excuse me raising
that thank you that's how they make
money and to a certain extent this is
the way the entertainment business is
going all over the place right Netflix
and cable television sell you a
subscription package we used to buy
music albums now we subscribe to Spotify
$10 a month all-you-can-eat but after
music right but if you're running in the
contrarian this party yeah if you're
owning an all-you-can-eat buffet you
can't charge less than the cost the
toast you have to have a reasonable
price and movie past estimates I really
enjoy the fact that you said amazon.com
when you think I'm old-fashioned that a
little company called amazon.com Derrick
it is always good to see you Derek
Thompson